[Musique]
les mercredis sportifs c'est reparti
pour le premier de la saison 56 jeunes
des clubs de volley de mulhouse
ensisheim kingersheim et guebwiller ont
répondu présent à l'invitation de l' us
mulhouse
les jeunes champions ont rencontré les
joueuses de l'as ptt mulhouse deux
heures d'entraînement pour développer
leur pratique au contact des championnes
de france en titre
[Musique]
et
tout au long de l'année seront ainsi
organisées des rencontres entre les
clubs pros de volley hand basket ou
encore de football et des jeunes
licenciés des clubs départementaux
c'est une action qui permet à des jeunes
qui n'ont pas forcément la possibilité
de côtoyer donc des sportifs de haut
niveau de le faire à ce moment là c'est
beaucoup de joie
le but pour nous c'est de fidéliser nos
jeunes dans la pratique et les amener à
côtoyer aussi d'aussi près leurs idoles
c'est une chance que peu de sport ont
réellement les joueuses ont la chance de
vivre de leur passion et c'est dans ce
genre d'événement qu'elles peuvent
transmettre ce qu'elles ont appris et
puis voilà focalise qu'elle donne du
rêve à ces jeunes
oui moi je pense c'est vraiment super
c'est une belle expérience pour nous
parce que c'est oui c'est qu'ils auront
quelque chose amusante pour nous et
c'est quelque chose belle pour elle je
pense parce que oui ce sont des enfants
et ils regarder voler au travers de ces
mercredis sportifs le département du
haut-rhin entend renforcer les liens
entre sportifs de nouveaux et jeunes des
clubs d'amateurs
s'ils sont nombreux à suivre le
championnat ou assister aux matches de
leur idole
les occasions de partager le terrain
avec elles sont plus rares pour les
éducateurs sportifs ces temps d'échangés
autour d'une passion commune sont une
véritable chante
c'est toujours un plaisir pour nous
entraîneurs de jeunes actuellement de
pouvoir voir nos jeunes côtoyé les
professionnels et ça c'est très
intéressant c'est aussi l'image qu'il
faut que les professionnels laissent de
côtoyer aussi les jeunes de la région
ont fait du département et de la ville
aussi une richesse on le prend comme une
chance pour nous d'avoir la possibilité
avec le pro et d'avoir la chance de
pouvoir travailler ensemble alors c'est
pas toujours ça mais c'est pas dans la
logique première des clubs mais on se
rend compte quand on arrive à fédérer
autant de monde autour d'un projet que
ça porte ses fruits que tout le monde
est gagnant au final parce que parce que
les gamins prennent plus de plaisir ils
sont plus favorables à la pratique
pour les championnes de la sppt outre
resserré les liens avec une partie de
leur public cette rencontre est aussi
l'occasion de transmettre leur savoir un
plaisir autant qu un break bienvenu dans
une saison fait d'entraînement et de
compétition poussé à leurs plus hauts
niveaux d'exigence
oui j'aime bien parce que c'est super
moi je suis encore jeune peu pour moi
donc oui c'est une expérience jouer un
peu cheap et avec le petit enfant parce
que oui ça bien kanaky qui le prennent
plus à coeur car qu'à d'autres là on
voit qu'elles prennent énormément de
plaisir à le faire et et voilà parce que
c'est c'est important de 2,2 voilà deux
de transmettre ce qu'on a reçues et de
donner à ces jeunes l'envi d'évoluer au
plus haut niveau
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas pour les
jeunes cet après midi est un temps de
perfectionnement même avec des
paillettes dans les yeux il faut assurer
manchette smash construction du jeu tout
il y est passé en revue
c'est forcément plus riches les enfants
sont dans une autre attitude qui sont
avec les joueuses pros au niveau de la
concentration au niveau de leur envie de
bien faire donc même si c'est qu'une
fois dans l'année
il en retire beaucoup de bénéfices
techniques j'ai vu déjà quelques amis
quelques quêtes et petits-enfants qu
avec une belle technique pour l'année
pour long qu'ils ont baiona qui ont dû
beau potentiel voilà maintenant et c'est
vrai qu'ils sont encore tout petit et
que le chemin pour accéder à un haut
niveau est encore très long mais c'est
vrai que
mais voilà il faut va falloir qu'ils
travaillent qu'ils apprennent et qui
grandissent sans brûler d'étapes
[Applaudissements]
la rencontre se tient dans le nouveau
complexe de l'air à bourtzwiller
là où se déroulent la plupart des
rencontres d'importance on le reçoit les
filles et l'équipe pro dans un cadre
vraiment idéal est très très
intéressante pour les jeunes qui
découvrent certains découvrent la salle
et ils sont heureux de participer et de
pouvoir pratiquer le sport avec les pros
dans un cadre commun celui ci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
financé avec l'appui du conseil
départemental le complexe sportif fait
la fierté les habitants du quartier
derrière le soutien aux associations
sportives au club la construction
d'équipements sportifs ou encore
l'organisation d'événements comme ce
mercredi sportif c'est toutes les
valeurs du sport quand on transmettre au
conseil départemental
las le sport c'est la détermination
c'est la persévérance c'est l'endurance
c'est donner c'est recevoir c'est
partager c'est toutes ces disciplines
qui qu'on aimerait inculquer à chacun de
nos jeunes sur les départements que le
sport apporte et c'est clair que le
département
l île il peut que encourager ce genre de
pratique parce qu'il est porteur de
valeurs et de valorisation à nos jeunes
y compris dans le quartier il ya
beaucoup de clubs qui sont du quartier
c'est aussi bien pour eux de côtoyer les
professionnels d'être présent dans la
salle a et d'échanger avec ses joueuses
professionnelles ans qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de faire 20
et qui sait si sur le parquet de
l'espace doller de bourtzwiller ne sont
pas en train dé gommer quelques futurs
champions
[Applaudissements]